well thanks everyone for attending this
and also to Mannin Ron and and Jack and
others for for inviting me and putting
on this really great symposium so we've
we've heard this two at nauseam already
but just just to set stage cancer is the
evolutionary process and it really has
this has some implications from both a
computational convenience perspective in
the sense that we can start to model
cancers as follow it following a
phylogenetic process and and so given
the rich amount of mathematical
development over the last several
decades this this really becomes a
really quite nice because we can
leverage all this and so we can we can
view a cancer as as composed of multiple
cells and these cells can be related by
descent through their mutations and such
that ancestral mutations are at the root
of the tree and these would be the
mutations that are part of the original
clonal expansion and descendent
mutations would be would occur later in
evolution in a subset in one cell which
then undergoes expansion and such that
the mutations here would be of low
prevalence in the tumor overall and and
mutually exclusive to those in other
phylogenetic branches and and so what
we're interested in in my group is is
really trying to understand how the
properties of evolution lead to the
clinical endpoints of interest in cancer
which is how does this relate to
treatment response progression
metastasis or even immune response and
so another conceptual idea here is that
these clones or cells have to navigate a
fitness landscape and this Fitness
landscape can be driven by many
different factors and it's a it's a
dynamic landscape as well such that if
there's a treatment intervention or a
dynamic immune response this landscape
shifts and so clones that may have a low
fitness at one point may then climb the
landscape such that they have higher
fitness at an
the point in time and so it if we start
to think about fitness landscapes it
helps us to interpret dynamics that we
might see in a in a clinical trajectory
of cancer and so fitness can be measured
it has several different properties I've
just listed three of them here one is
that genetic diversity is a complex a
quantity only partially explains
phenotypic variation and so if we can
start to elucidate what components of
genetic diversity actually de phenotypic
variation which is what selection
actually acts on then we might we might
get closer to be able to quantify
fitness in cancer clothes the second
idea is population dynamics so the cells
that the cell populations that comprise
a tumor the Constituent clones at a one
time point that that evolves over time
such that the composition of a tumor may
change from something that looks like
this to something that looks like this
and so being able to quantify measure
model these population dynamics gives us
some notion of a component of fitness
and finally is the role of micro
environmental select the pressures so
these tumors are involving in very
dynamic and atomic landscapes that are
subject to like I said immune evasion
immune response and also a particular
environments of metastatic sites that
are very quite variable across our human
anatomy and so understanding this gives
us a route towards that so hopefully
I'll show you examples of where we've
addressed each of these problems and and
and and have made some steps towards our
goal of inferring these Fitness
landscapes so let's start with what
mutations impact phenotype so this this
part will be a very reminiscent of what
you just heard from from Josh we
developed a method called X seek and and
what we what we have made the assumption
is that by integrating mutations with
gene
expression we're using gene expression
as a sort of proxy it quite a quite a
distant proxy for phenotype but but
nonetheless because of the abundance of
data we're making this assumption that
if we could ascertain which mutations
are impacting gene expression then that
gives us a little closer to those
mutations that are functionally active
in the cell and so so we developed this
method clacks deacon so it takes as
input matrix of mutations and patients
this is binary matrix is this gene
mutated in this patient it takes the
same dimensionality matrix of expression
continuous valued expression
measurements in those same patients and
then borrowing from from been the the
notion of an influence graph where we
have connected genes and we want to
ascertain does the mutation impact
expression in its connected genes in
this influence graph okay so so this is
a probabilistic graphical model where we
have several layers the first layer is
at the gene level so given this this
matrix across the population of patients
does the gene when mutated impact
expression that's just a binary random
variable then we have the mutation level
binary variable does the mutation in the
patient of interest impact the
expression in that patient so we get
down to patient level inference and and
I'll show you the impact of that in a
few slides then this is just the latent
variable that suggests whether a gene is
upregulated or downregulated and so if
you explode this out this this here this
mutation connects to all of its
neighbors in the influence graph and so
that's what this plate is here and then
and then we have the directionality of
influence up is it up regulated or
download you laid and so when we when we
complete our inference we get something
that looks like this where we have the
mutation of interest if this is bright
red then this suggests the the posterior
probability that that mutation in that
patient is influencing expression is
high and so you can see here are the
neighbors of this gene and the influence
graph and
the saturation of the color here
represents the degree to which that gene
is is disrupted in this particular
patient so so there's two modes that we
we run this this model in one is the
cysts mode which says which is does the
mutation impact the expression of that
particular gene and then there's a trans
mode which is does this mutation impact
all of its neighbors so just the results
from the cysts mode this is really a as
we've shown is really potent in
identifying potential tumor suppressor
candidate so this is where loss of
function mutation or deletion has
essentially disrupted or depleted the
expression of that gene in the in the
sample and so this is just the
application of this to the TCGA
pan-cancer assist 12 tumor types almost
3,000 tumors 500,000 mutations these are
the tumor types here and and so just to
point out so so all of these genes are
show evidence of having cysts regulated
activity when mutated and so that
they're marked here by cancer gene
census genes so that the traditional
players p53 RB 1 NF 1 p-10 these are
known tumor suppressor genes and then we
have some novel predictions shown in
orange and these are be predictions
where integration of expression has has
actually reached into in frequently
mutated genes much very reminiscent of
what what Josh showed in the sense that
these are genes that were not predicted
by frequency based methods as drivers
that just look at the mutation in the in
the context of the population and so so
here's music which is a tool that just
looks at the frequency of mutation
relative to its background mutation rate
and identifies jeans that look like
they're significantly mutated you can
see that there are a lot of genes here
that essentially don't have any
predictions for music but have have all
the hallmarks of a tumor suppressor
phenotype in in these cancer types and
these mutations they all have the
properties of loss of function mutations
stop codon mutations frameshifting
insertions and deletions they tend to
occur in hemizygous deletion regions or
peter by allelic lee and activated and
so so if you read the paper you can look
at all the gory details we have
essentially a diagrams for every single
one of these genes that shows the
distribution of mutations and and and
there's very strong evidence that these
are probably rare candidate tumor
suppressors so in summary this showed 30
novel candidates from our analysis and
cysts and then 80 novel candidates 89
novel candidates in trans and so this is
what the trans type of analysis looks
like and and the implication here is
that at the patient because we're we're
inferring the disruption of expression
at the patient level this has a
tremendous implications so this is all
of the cases in the endometrial TCGA
data set that have beta catenin
mutations so beta katina mutation is
known to constitutively active a twin
signaling of the wind signaling pathway
this is the the actual mechanism by
which these cancers are thought to arise
and so these are the genes in the wind
signaling pathway and in the columns
here are are the patient's you can see
that there's a fair number of patients
wear these jeans are abundantly over
regulated and and and and these genes
here are actually down regulated so
there's a tremendous disruption to the
wind signaling pathway here in these
patients that exhibit beta katina
mutations but if we look at these
patients over here about twenty five
percent of patients that Harbor beta
katina mutation do not show this
activation of the wind signaling pathway
so so if we were just to look at try to
diagnose this patient or actually make
some decision based on the presence of
the mutation chances are that these
patients would behave very differently
to some treatment or intervention than
these patients here and so by doing
patient level mutation activity
stratification we can really separate
the patients into two groups and as it
turns out these are patients that are
hyper mutators and so so actually the
the mutation is likely to be a
sender event in those particular
patients but is clearly driving in these
patients here okay so that's a one way
to attack the idea of what mutations are
actually impacting phenotype so let's
move on to the second idea which is
population dynamics so we've we've
discussed this a few times at the
meeting this is a nice figure from from
Nico's paper where whereby we can use
the the digital capacity of the
sequencing devices to measure illegal
prevalence in a DNA mixture and and so
allele prevalence has some relationship
to the proportion of cells in the
mixture that Harbor the mutation but
it's not a direct relationship and so we
have to do some some transformation of
the data in order to ascertain what what
percentage of cells actually Harbor my
money mutation of interest once we have
the percentage of cells of several
different mutations then we can start to
reconstruct what this picture might look
like so what is this what is are the
Constituent clones that make up my tumor
so when we start we actually all these
bubbles might be gray these cells here
and we don't know what the composition
is and so what we want to try to do is
from deeply sequence mutations is
reconstruct what this picture look like
and so the two terms of interest here
Arlee lick prevalence which is the the
the number of reads that Harbor the
mutation over the total and then the
cellular prevalence which is the
proportion of cells in the tumor that
Harbor the mutation so when we do deeps
will perform deep sequencing through pcr
or capture whatever method you choose
the illegal fractions end up being a
compound measure of several different
factors so we have an unknown proportion
of of non malignant cells these can be
lymphocytes can be stroma the so so that
will impact this measurement here we
have the unknown population structure
which I mentioned already so if the
mutation of interest is is for example
in this in this orange population it may
be there
in fifteen percent of cells and so that
will impact the allelic prevalence and
then finally we have this concept of
mutational genotype so in a normal
diploid genome like this if all else
being equal if all sales Harbor a hatch
was a heterozygous mutation then the
allele fraction will be fifty percent
but if all sales harbored a homozygous
mutation like this whereby we had let's
say loss of heterozygosity followed by a
copy number change then then all of the
alleles would would show the mutation so
you'd have a little fraction of a
hundred percent here we have a copy
number change followed by mutation so we
have four copies of the genome of that
and that would yield a legal fraction of
25% so you can see that in these three
different scenarios the cellular
prevalence is equivalent but the allele
fraction is very different so we need to
be able to grapple with all these
different factors and so we developed a
model called hyclone that can that can
resolve these these different
explanations for the same allele
fraction and the input the PI clone
looks like something like this we assume
that we have data from multiple samples
and so we have the the rows here just
the locus the mutation of interest and
then we have the legal fraction for all
of the different samples and then
actually we have an independent measure
of copy number at each one of these
samples as well in order to allow us to
to leverage that information to D
convolute these mixtures so it's another
bayesian hierarchical model you can tell
I like this kind of modeling the three
parameters of interest are that we want
to cluster mutations that are assumed to
be in the same cells we want to estimate
their prevalence and then we we we have
this parameter that we marginalize over
which is the mutational genotype so this
is all detailed in the paper and I'm not
going to spend too much time on that but
this is the most important which is the
this is the conceptual output and so
what's shown here is we have multiple
measurements of of these mutations so
they're about let's say 150 mutations
and
experiment that we executed measured and
and this was an engineered experiment
where we actually had serial dilutions
of two cell lines with non overlapping
sets of mutations so so we mix them at
known proportions in order to simulate
what would happen if we could measure
one clone growing at the expense of the
other and they had some mutations in
common so they cease the stage so that
axis here is the inferred cellular
prevalence of the mutations and and then
these the the colors here represent
clusters of mutations that essentially
travel together that we believe when
they travel together it entitles us to
think that these are representing one
clone and if they certainly if these
lines cross these these must be in a
different clone because they kick the
abundance of these clones can't go up
and down at the same time okay so this
allows us to infer these evolutionary
trajectories and you might then project
that here's a clone that's undergoing
expansion here's a clone that's
undergoing extinction so that's
theoretically what it looks like so how
do we apply this to real real real world
situations so we've been measuring these
population dynamics through temporal
sampling of tumors so we've now executed
a study where where we wanted to compare
what are the clonal dynamics in in
transformed follicular lymphoma versus
progress follicular lymphoma so
follicular lymphoma is an indolent
lymphoma a subset of patients will
undergo a histological transformation at
some point in their clinical trajectory
and what happens is they get a sudden
onset of symptoms and the tumor goes
from this very indolent disease to
something that's very aggressive and the
patients that undergo this
transformation have very poor outcomes
so they stopped responding to therapy
and many succumb and then these are
progress where these are patients where
there's there go on treatment
combination amino and chemotherapy and
but they don't respond they don't they
don't they progress while on treatment
or within two years of starting
treatment so these are the two clinical
endpoints
major consideration in the management of
this disease and then we compare these
to the two long term non progressor so
these are patients essentially do fairly
well so the workflow that we executed
look something like this did whole
genome sequencing of matched pairs of
the diagnostic specimen and the relapse
specimen and then plotted their illegal
fractions from inferred from whole
genome sequencing on an axis so this is
the allele fraction of mutations for the
diagnostic versus the versus the relapse
t1 vs t 2 and you can see that their
mutations on the axes here which
suggests that there are there's some
mutations in clones that are probably
not present at diagnosis and then there
are some mutations in the diagnostic
clones that actually don't expand in the
in the relapse biopsy so we selected
some of these mutations and perform deep
sequencing and then inferred the the
seller their prevalence of these
mutations through PI clone and then
schematically just represent them with
these bubbles so here this is a this is
mutations that probably represent the
ancestral clone here and then and then
we can look at the clones that are
essentially on the axes so this is a
clone that was very rare if if existing
at all in the diagnostic specimen that
has come to dominate the relapse
specimen what you can see is essentially
there are no clones here in the middle
of this diagram and so that suggests
that the the composition of the t2
biopsy is essentially a almost
non-existent here in the t1 biopsy and
has that made tremendous implications
for be able to predict what patients are
going to respond and which which ones
will transform so we can project this
onto a clone phylogeny and then also
look at the composition of those clones
in the t1 vs t 2 so that's the the
workflow and the result here is that the
transform samples exhibited this pattern
where whether that I mentioned where we
had really extreme clonal dynamics in
between the diagnostic and the
transformational biopsy and there are
some hints as to what mutations might be
driving that
but the main story here is that the
composition of the the diagnostic
specimen is very different than the
transformation specimen even though the
clonally related and we did do multiple
samples of the diagnostic specimen to
ensure that this wasn't just a sampling
bias that you might have missed some
clones so so the story here is that
there's there's a rapid clonal expansion
of a very rare clone in the t1 samples
by contrast those patients that are
progressed on therapy you can see that
there's actually quite a lot of clothes
that are actually in the middle of this
diagram which suggests that even in the
presence of this big selective pressure
of therapy the the intrinsic properties
of resistance are probably already
encoded at the diagnostic specimen and
so so it means that the dynamics here
are relatively stable the clonal
composition you can see that a lot of
the clones are present in both the t1
and t2 so there's a there's one here is
pink one this green one this blue one
and similarly for this case here so so
the the story here is that by actually
measuring these clonal dynamics we get
two very different models of progression
in these different clinical endpoints of
the same disease so transformation is
underpinned by a dramatic clonal
expansion of a very rare clone that
comes to dominate the t2 specimen and
this can happen by the way without any
kind of intervention whatsoever some of
these patients are actually just put on
observation and so it's independent of
treatment it's also independent of time
to transformation so we had one case
that look like this that was under
observation for 15 years and then
transformed another case that was under
observation for just six months and
transformed it an exhibit exactly the
same pattern so you can have this
pattern seems to be independent of of
time to transformation and also of
treatment whereas in the in the
treatment relapse cases where these are
cases that progressed on therapy you can
see a lot of the architecture is
preserved so this green clone has
maintained the blue one the pink one the
steel one etc there's some dynamics but
but most of the architecture is
preserved and the implications for this
is that
the pre-existing phenotype is already
established at the time of diagnosis and
so there is some hope here that we could
you leverage the the clonal composition
of the diagnostic specimen to predict
what what what patients might exhibit
resistance or refractoriness to therapy
okay so so that's just an application of
clonal dynamics and population dynamics
so the major question that arises is
there any kind of deterministic process
is driving this or is it just a random
stochastic observation and and so the
only way to really resolve this is to be
able to do repeated experiments you
can't do that in a patient so we've
engaged a a collaboration with sam
aparicio he's the chair of breast cancer
research at the Cancer Agency and he's
been developing xenograft patient drive
xenograft lines of primary breast
cancers with the intention to to look
for susceptibility to drugs in in these
preclinical model systems we we started
asking questions about you know what are
the evolutionary dynamics of of taking a
patient tumor and and and removing it
from an immune surveilled patient and
putting it into an immunodeficient mouse
in the xenograft and so that's the other
important aspect of this is that these
are serially passage xenografts such
that when the tumor grows to a certain
size the mouse's is sacrificed the
tumors excise and then that materials re
transplanted into another Mouse and so
essentially this we have this
longitudinal time series repeated we can
we can repeatedly assay the population
over time and so what we found and most
the details are in the paper here but
what we found is that over time we we
observed significant clone dynamics and
and even saw these these sweeps that are
actually reminiscent of the histological
transformation follicular lymphoma and
and and so we basically what's what we
concluded here is that by taking a
patient material and putting it into a
new environment
the massive clonal dynamics can actually
occur and this is this is an assumption
that the patient drive Xena graphs
recapitulate the biology of the patient
tumor and we're suggesting that in some
cases this is likely to be violated that
assumption we validated these clonal
dynamics in with single cell sequencing
that it won't have time to go over but
the point I really want to make is that
we did these repeated measures whereby
we did biological replicates and took
the same population and engrafted them
into independent mice and and what's
shown here is that across four different
mice in this example the green clone
expands at the expense of the red clone
in every single in every single example
and so there's some reproducibility to
the patterns of these clonal dynamics
and that really does suggest that
there's a deterministic property that's
driving this process and maybe some
alleles are actually have a major
selective coefficient and in selection
is acting on those on those alleles so
this also sets a stage because it
suggests that these deterministic
properties might be predictive
especially in the context of drug
selection experiments so there's an
intervention and we see these
reproducible dynamics then we can really
start to ascertain what are the
mechanisms behind that and but the first
step is to actually see these
reproducible dynamics and so we've done
that at this point okay so moving on
here so the last component was micro
environmental selective pressures and in
into study this we've been looking at
high-grade serous ovarian cancers these
are ovarian cancers that exhibit
extremely poor or five-year survival
rates they many of the patients respond
initially to standard of care platinum
taxing therapy but nearly eighty percent
will recur they're characterized by p53
mutations and braca abnormalities
leading to homologous recombination
deficiency and so they have this
genomically unstable phenotype
and and then at the time of diagnosis
because these tumors develop within a
the peritoneal cavity there's lots of
opportunity for cells to move around and
so when patients present there's often a
high degree of spread so sometimes we
see bilateral disease will often see
foci on the on the omentum or other
other organs within the peritoneal
cavity so so we engaged in this study
with surgeon Jessica mcalpine who's
treating these patients and and what
Jessica did is essentially at the time
of primary debulking surgery is to
harvest all of these tissues and and
label essentially where they came from
and then what we did is is is sequenced
the genomes and and and profile they're
a clonal composition such that we could
draw these diagrams so first thing we
did has established a clone phylogeny in
this and this was done through in some
cases single cell sequencing in other
cases through deep targeted sequencing
using the workflow they showed and then
what then what we did is we could ask
what is the clonal composition of each
of these samples and so so one thing to
observe here is that here's a sample
that's left over a b2 that's composed of
multiple clones so this is a what we
would call it a very diverse sample
whereas other samples are are very
homogeneous so they're only made up of
one clone and across the different sites
those clones were different and so this
is consistent with a model that there's
a site of a clonal origin if you will
where there's lots of diversity
happening and then there's a then
there's uni directional spread to all
these different sites okay almost done
so so this is this is one model where
where we saw this one side of diversity
and then you need directions spread to
all these different sites the
contrasting model that we saw was in
some patients we saw something that
looked like this where we had multiple
clones for example this red and and
yellow clone that coexisted in multiple
different sites so this suggested that
either they travel together
these clones travel together or there is
repeated mixing and bi-directional
spread throughout the peritoneal cavity
in these cases and so we have these
contrasting modes of spread that can be
tracked using these clonal lineages so
why does this really matter well if we
if we had one patient for which we had
time series data so this was we had the
patient at diagnosis an initial relapse
to the brain and then a subsequent
relapse again to to the to the area in
the pelvis and and so what we found is
that act diagnosis there was a sample
that had this this diversity property
this one down here and actually both of
the clones that dominated each of the
metastasis so this one here this yellow
one dominated the brain metastases and
this red one dominated the pelvic
relapse where these were already present
at diagnosis so if we could have
captured or done some analysis on this
sample and and decomposed the
constituent clones and this in the
sample then we could might have
intervened in a way that would / would
have prevented these metastases so this
this this relapse is driven by this
clone and this relapse driven by by that
clone there so it has implications for
for being able to intervene at an early
stage prior to to spread so then just to
conclude so we we've all all in
agreement that cancer arises from
individual evolutionary processes and
hopefully what I've shown you is that
there are attractively measurable
properties and a couple of computational
modeling that lead us closer to being
able to ascertain the fitness landscape
I showed you genotype to phenotype
inference reproducible population
dynamics are going to be a central
ingredient and then the spatial
distributions suggest that there are
clones that are being selected for
differentially in different micro
environments and so I think that the
stage is set now for characterization of
tumors as evolving biological systems
with quantifiable fitness landscapes
there's a lot of work to be done to get
there
because we have to now we have to now
introduce the mathematics behind
population dynamics and fitness and
selection but the measurement technology
and just the inference of these
properties i think is now well
established so so now I'll just thank my
collaborators Jessica mcalpine and David
Huntsman Sam apareció Blake jokes Randy
gas going and I really a cadre of
amazing graduate students that I've
learned from every day and Ruth Andrew
McPherson Fong Chan addy steiff Jerry
ding and Peter i rue and last well thank
the funders and thank you for your
attention in your follicular lymphoma
example you've got this deeply rooted
branch coming off and one possibility
seems to me that the deeply rooted
branch is this bunch of functioning an
independent cancer right this it's so
early that it's sharing what like
fifteen percent of the mutation course
okay and is is the it is there a model
for that for that recurrence or
progression to be more similar to
another different type of cancer all
together yeah so that's a great question
so one of the markers one of the
mutations that seems to track with this
pattern our CC and III mutations and
this is a hallmark of burkitt lymphoma
actually which is really aggressive type
of b-cell lymphoma and so what seems to
be happening is there's acquisition of
these driver mutations that are known to
be the early events in in other b-cell
malignancies that are acquired at some
point and and then there's there seems
they seem to have a selective
coefficient that is quite extraordinary
in the sense that proliferation then
just explodes so the the problem is is
that the core sampling suggests that
we're only doing two time points here so
it's very difficult to ascertain when is
the mutation acquired there's some
evidence to suggest that so we've done
digital PCR on some of these alleles and
there's actually zero evidence of
of these alleles in the in in some of
the diagnostic specimens so that I don't
ever has to be my position would be that
that this is functionally independent
cancer in a in a sort of equivalent of
MDS all right you've got some Fremont
pre-cancer state that's sort of
hyperproliferative but but and and it
yields some of them like this indolent
follicular lymphoma but the progenitor
of that Fang is hyperproliferative on
his own but would not even yield the
follicular lymphoma phenotype and that
and that the transformative events that
yields is highly progressive nasty thing
is happening that founder population
that right is is like a is like a
warning sign for the independent thing
right that you know you're likely to get
this flick lymphoma first but it's not
necessarily the same disease in any way
shape or form I think that's that's
absolutely true and I think that I mean
histological transformation almost
defines that right so there's a even the
microscope these these cells look
different they have large nuclei and
they're now so so there is this
morphological change that accompanies
this but but the actual events that lead
to that is still it's still kind of
murky and but what's was quite
extraordinary is these the the clonal
dynamics are are extreme there is really
the most extreme you could observe
stuff because of the experiment of
something or the immune response that
was compromised yeah so I showed you the
most extreme example out of out of 15 so
just to illustrate the point but even in
that very complex example the dynamics
were reproducible so in some cases we
didn't see such extreme dynamics we only
saw moderate dynamics in some cases
actually the clonal architecture is
mostly preserved only only slightly
changing so it there isn't a universal
pattern that we saw that you could you
can make the case that lack of immune
system is allowing chaos to then a crew
but in that's an assumption we're making
it a great privilege you showed in the
how am I Newark loan and presentation
later becomes dominant that relapse
after treatment right you reckon this is
due to selection pressure by the mic the
environment or is that and in fact all
the selectors we've been used by the
weather's by their treatment whether
there and so what's yeah so actually
it's paradoxical exits that was the
interesting thing about comparing the
cases that progressed on treatment
versus the histologically transformed
cases so so you'd anticipate that the
cases that were treated would have to go
through those clones I'd have to go
through some evolutionary bottleneck and
actually would would it have these
selective sweeps but actually what we
observed was the opposite so so in those
cases the clone architecture is mostly
preserved so the diagnostic specimen was
actually very reflective of what we saw
in the relapse on treatment but the the
surprising finding was that in these
untreated cases that transformed that's
that's when we observe this massive
selective sweet so so that suggests that
it is an allele that has a very strong
selective coefficient that is able to
emerge from
the neutrality assumption so this brain
metastases that you showed was it was
untreated oh sorry I thought you're
talking about the follicular lymphoma
patients that's to the the brain brain
metastases was ovary yeah so that that
was treat those would have been treated
cases yeah so great talk sex is rough in
the population dynamics fault I was I
was quite surprised that you say there's
one group that has additional clonal
expansion that the other one tends to a
little variation maybe you could comment
a bit on the time scale of all of the
air variation is and then towards the
interpretation I mean I'm not so
convinced that even if if those with
little change have level drug resistance
which I think was the explanation for
that I would expect even in that
situation there there's a large number
of additional mutation that can increase
fitness so by weezer yes so so to
address the first part I'll just show
you the sum of the variation in the time
scales yeah yeah so so what what what's
pretty we found is so you see that some
of these transformation cases the the
time scales are very short was the
extreme example was 15 years and in
those two cases that I point out both
were just put under observation there
was no therapy applied so that suggests
that the the pattern that of these kind
of dramatic expansions is independent of
time there's not it's not just you we
don't didn't only observe that pattern
in the in the one with it large time
interval we saw in short time intervals
as well and then so with it with respect
to the second question so well I think I
think what we're observing is is quite
paradoxical in the sense that we're
treating in the second group there were
treating these patients with multi-agent
therapy and and the the claw
architecture for the most part is is
conserving it's really just relative to
the dramatic expansions we saw in the
transform cases the architecture is
mostly preserved there was some dynamic
still but but we saw clones that were
readily detectable in the diagnostic
specimen that word is still there so
they hadn't been eradicated by the
treatment it wasn't some new cancer that
has arisen in that time interval and so
jealous n so the ones with nothing has
changed that
oh I see yeah yeah the time skills and
when you observe it can let alone
explain it it can it can alone explain
it because we see you can see that there
are some cases in in this regime where
where the the biopsies were very close
together and then and and actually in
some cases we had you know sometime in
between the lab specimens so hey let's
thank the speakers again